the senate passed a bill yesterday and
this is going to go to the house so it's
not if it's not official yet but they
passed a bill
unanimously establishing juneteenth as
a national holiday and i think we have
some
of the footage of this potentially
historic moment let's watch let's watch
some of this
mr president i asked consent the senate
proceed to the consideration of esres
269 submitted earlier today
the clerk will report senate resolution
269
designated june 19 2021 as juneteenth
independence day
in recognition of june 19 1865 the date
on which
news of the end of slavery reached the
slaves in the southwestern states
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
i ask unanimous consent the resolution i
don't know the preamble why exactly am i
playing this i don't know
um i don't know why i'm asking you that
question i should have answered that
really i tell you why
because this is this is the end of uh of
racism
this is this is the senate curing racism
finally
and i feel like that's historic it's
also historic because
all of these people who just found out
what juneteenth was like last year
now they just found out last year much
of the country just found out last year
what it is and now it is a deeply
important
holiday to them that should be
celebrated
not only in america but across the
planet and indeed probably
across the entire solar system um
here's what i'll uh just two quick
things about this
first of all in
looking at it objectively in a vacuum
having a holiday to celebrate the
abolition of slavery
makes sense makes makes a lot of sense i
could see that
but i have a problem and i've and as you
know i've been saying this
for years i am opposed in principle
to anything that is done to appease or
impress a mob okay anything that is done
with fraudulent intentions to appease or
oppress them up
and that includes tearing down statues
it includes
declaring holidays it includes anything
if there is something worth doing you do
it because it's worth doing
you don't do it all in a mad rush
because you're trying to impress the mob
or you're afraid of them or whatever and
that's of course what's happening here
it's not a coincidence that we had the
riots and we have all all of this and
blm
um and now they're saying oh you know
what uh yeah
let's make juneteenth national holiday
it's the same thing i said with with the
statues
i think a lot of the statues that were
torn down
were were not were not deserving of that
at all and uh and should have remained
based on their own merits there may have
been a few statues that
you could make a reasonable argument for
taking them down
but even with those statues i said all
along i
i oppose tearing them down now
under these conditions
all in one mad dash if it was not for
that if it wasn't for the mass hysteria
and a community just on their own got
together and said hey we don't really
want this statue let's take it down
fine but under the circumstances
that's where i think it becomes a
problem also
i also have another problem um
with p if you if you as the democrats do
in the senate
if you hate america and don't think that
america itself
is worth celebrating and in fact you
don't even think anymore that
that it's it's worth standing for the
national anthem
and you also think as they would tell us
and have said that racism today
is worse than it's ever been it's all
been downhill
then i don't know if you're necessarily
equipped
to come up with new national holidays
i mean i i guess that's the deal maybe
we should make it's like okay you want
to you want to
make juneteenth the national holiday
abolition of slavery makes sense
sorry are you saying now that we can
celebrate america and we is that what
you're saying we can be proud of
americans
everyone should stand for the for the uh
for the anthem
july 4th comes along we celebrate that
and be happy and proud
putting all the apologies aside we're
moving past that is that what you're
saying
[Music]
i think you really got to pick a lane it
would seem to me well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt well show if you
did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content